architecture is our every work is a work
of art architecture is the greatest of
the arts and compasses thinking that
other arts don't even deal with like the
relationship of the work to the
individual human being the person who
used personal experiences that the
person is sees it and how that person
perceives of that space you know there's
a old adage that a sculptor can make a
square wheel and an architect has to
make a round one you have a certain
responsibility not just to your client
not just to the people using the
building but to the public at large and
what you do well I don't say well
buildings are architecture first of all
so there's lots of buildings that have
nothing to do with architecture they
have to do with economics they have to
do with enclosure but I wouldn't
consider them works of architecture to
be a work of architecture is creating a
work of art
you